hello my beautiful girls I am so excited
that you are here today watching this
video we are talking about how to
inspire your man to be back in his
masculine energy so you know the drill
guys I've got my kombucha and my notes
we are diving right in
you're not a kombucha person I can't a
kombucha is like a back washed in my
head gives me anxiety bro
that's my booty in the bathroom I
[ __ ] it [ __ ] yo oh it's just
Audrey can't boost I said [ __ ] you give
me a laxative
because I never thought
it came in as green aloe water and it
came out as [ __ ] chocolate melty rain
because that [ __ ] was crazy yeah
you know when you throw up
from your ass
you know when you go to the bathroom you
got to take your whole shirt off you'll
be like oh
[ __ ] let me let me put on my vote
dwelling outfit about to go fall out on
this man all right all right guys I was
sick a couple days ago and I'm still a
little bit sick so if I start coughing
please just bear with me it's been a
rough Journey but I'm getting people who
look me in the eyes and smile at the
same time I feel like they're they're
[ __ ] my soul
tonight
like it's very intimidating once I was
just like hi
I'm feeling great today how are you
feeling
yeah freeze how you doing
like like it's a very intense thing it's
not a bad thing you keep doing it you
know do you so anyways back to the video
how to inspire your man to be back in
his masculine energy and I think the
reason that I get this question so much
is because the world is out of balance
right now so many men are in their
feminine energies hey fellas you heard
that she said so many [ __ ] is [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] I smell [ __ ] is that you
man I smell [ __ ] is that you guys
you [ __ ] is [ __ ] uh you know let's
all right that's a 50 Cent song so you
aren't aware
I smell [ __ ] is that you Ty y'all
[ __ ] is [ __ ] bro she calling out you
calling you guys out some of y'all in
your feminine energy
just because I paint my nails she just
said straight [ __ ] like shout outs to
hurt man shout outs to her this is this
is the hood translation so many men are
in the feminine [ __ ] hey man this video
has turned out way more fun than I
thought it was gonna be this great shout
out to her there are three things that
I'm going to share with you today that
you can do to switch this Inspire man to
be back in his masculine energy because
that is a beautiful relationship Dynamic
that we want for you so
why are you doing this bro
oh my God my ear doesn't work anymore
I might need some kombucha in there
because I wish I could diarrhea out of
my ear I can't hear bro
[Music]
can you imagine the ears
all right let's keep watching oh yeah
there's a bunch of people watching right
now like what the [ __ ] is kombucha and
that's how I know you're uncultured
let's Carry On which isn't not a bad
thing
uh I'm judging let's carry on should no
passport heavyness
I'm talking to you American so
masculine and feminine energy
out taking action it's about thinking
using logic and doing if you feel that
you as the woman are the one who is
leading the relationship then the
relationship Dynamic is probably out of
balance and you guys always see me use
this example but I talk about feminine
and masculine energies being like a
magnet being drawn together when you are
in your feminine energy your man is in
his masculine energy that's when you
guys are drawn together this is called
polarity and it's very very strong
attraction however this video is
referencing the couples that have
switched so what's going on bro why are
you laughing she's saying whenever
you're in your masculine energy and
she's in your feminine energy you know
you need that's where you guys match and
I'm like yeah but sometimes me and my
girl were moving a couch and I'm like yo
get in this math get in this masculine
energy and move this [ __ ] [ __ ] let's go
thank you my [ __ ] thank you
and we and she's like no sorry what
we're actually gonna do is we make the
lemonade you move the house
all right sorry there's a bunch of women
at home flexing right now
the very first thing that you can do to
change the relationship Dynamic Inspire
this masculine energy back into your man
oh he's right now there's a chance to
combat how do you think this is gonna go
is there a chance it's to appreciate him
appreciate the things that he does that
is masculine if you notice that there
are things that your man still does
during the day or at night that are
masculine because he probably does some
things that are still in his masculine
energy I want you to notice those now
more than ever before and I'll give you
an example
[Music]
listen this is our juvenile energy okay
yeah please forgive us yo so I use this
on Tick Tock but let's say that your man
picks a place for you guys to go to
dinner tonight let's say or maybe he
says babe we're gonna I'm gonna go and
get some Chinese food for us tonight
this is a chance for you to appreciate
his masculine energy this is what you
say babe it feels so good for me when
you just take charge and you decide what
we're having for dinner I love being
able to just come home and you decide
what we're having I love being able to
not have to think or plan or decide what
it is you have such great taste and I
really really trust you she's right
but you don't have to make it that long
yeah
[Music]
the examples in the same fair you know
what I mean you know what I mean fast
maybe maybe but but she is a 100 right
yes like choose the restaurant sometimes
understand she's absolutely right but
don't say that long-ass sentence that's
gonna be like
it's it feels sus you can just say hey
ladies okay the way she's giving ladies
advice to say nice things and we agree
we'll tell you what we want to hear we
just want to hear I like it when you
just choose for me
oh but she's a hundred percent right
absolutely don't keep don't keep it long
because if because if you keep it long
then it sounds like it really sounds
certain it sounds like you're
manipulating yeah yeah yeah yeah I
really like it I love it when you keep
me in my feminine energy by getting your
masculinity making no that's too much
that's too much too much too much sauce
just tell them I like it when you choose
she's a hundred percent right though so
I'll give you another example
that tea
give him a kiss one day and say you know
you just make me feel like a princess
you are just my knight in shining armor
these things that you do for me no no
no no
no
you know what hold up we're speaking
from our experience yes I would highly
doubt any of the people I know would
like this kind of warden fair but but
maybe you guys in the comments do you
like long compliments like this babe I
love the fact that you make me feel like
such a princess did you guys like that I
don't think the men do
if I'm honest but I could be wrong so
I'm gonna be open but I don't think I am
no no you don't think I know for a fact
the long [ __ ] oh miss me with that
[ __ ] absolutely let's hit it so do
you notice that your feminine energy
really comes alive when you are with a
masculine man
when you feel safe when you feel that he
is just protecting you when he is
providing for you and he is loving on
you your feminine energy can almost
blossom in a new way this is the exact
same thing that happens for the
masculine energy when he is around the
feminine energy he feels like he gets to
thrive being the protector being the
provider looking out for you and caring
for you you want your man to have this
opportunity because it feels just as
good for him as it does for you to be
the feminine energy
yeah I would agree
do you I think you act more tradically
masculine when you're around a woman and
that you become more protective you
become more
territorial if you want or whatever yeah
I'll probably agree okay the example
that I always use is dancing and I use
dancing because not only are you
releasing some of that blocked emotion
in your body but you are flowing you're
being present you're happy and you're
connecting to both you are creative and
your sensual energy you need this to be
in your feminine energy you need your
body to feel good bro I love dancing is
this Big Sean say I've been my feminine
energy because I like dancing
bruh bro I was getting along with this
girl I've been here at the club every
weekend I'm going out dancing tonight
bro
you can also look like self-care it can
look like doing face masks wearing cute
pajamas around the house taking care of
your skin your hair your diet everything
it can also look like going out with
girlfriends connecting with other girls
who are in their phone and energy yes
when you go out with your girls when
your girlfriends it raises their massive
energy but you know why because you
leave us the [ __ ] alone for two minutes
I agree
she's that girl's been right all this
[ __ ] time
I'm not even kidding y'all yeah
sometimes you chilling with your
girlfriends yo do your thing do your
[ __ ] thing true live your life
oh my man just doesn't step up he
doesn't do things
and I have to be the one to do it and
then I ask them well why are you doing
it or who's the one doing it and then
they say well I am it needs to get done
if you lean back Release Control release
the pressure for it to get done it is
going to get done and it won't be done
by you so if you can lean back and give
your man that space to really step up
and take charge chances are he will and
he's probably not having the opportunity
to do it right now
so I want you to really drop into your
body and be aware of when this is
happening and I'll give you some
examples too so
um I also want to say that your
masculine energy if you aren't aware
that you're doing this what it looks
like is you feel like you are physically
leaning forward like you are planning
like you are taking action that you are
not in your body that you are not
relaxed but you're instead in your head
and you're doing you're taking action
you aren't your man's mother you aren't
his nurse you aren't his teacher you
aren't his therapist you are his woman
let go of all those roles yeah lean back
is like don't feel the need to impose
yourself and everything and let them
make some decisions in the whole thing
yeah that's actually speaking back in
the middle but sometimes if we don't
yeah sometimes we don't dance we put up
your pants and a little Rockaway yeah
yeah yeah yeah absolutely be back I know
some people because they've been single
for so long or whatever for the idea of
someone else making any decisions for
them is like careful or it's just like
you're giving up and you know sometimes
those Dynamics can lead to about a come
so I understand why people are like
reluctant to do that when you find a
partner you can do that with and you let
them choose oftentimes it's better like
I don't know what it is but pretty much
every girl I've ever did just like the
fact that I take charge of situations
and for them it's relaxing it's like oh
I'm worthy I don't have to think it's
like you just choose where we're going
to eat you take care of the plans gender
only for this stuff or you know you take
care of whatever it is and you organize
it I'm like yeah and for me it's just
easier because I'm like this needs to
get done get it done you feel me so
but I've also taken some resistance to
that where there's a lot of black okay
so I I do a lot of partner dancing when
you do partner dancing all right as a
lead and you have you dance it with the
follow which is the woman generally okay
one thing that a lot of poor followers
do is they call do something called back
leading okay or for you laymens who
don't dance it's called backseat driving
which everybody [ __ ] go yo yo turn
left my [ __ ] turn left turn left yo go
right my G I got a bit around nobody's
trying to hear that no no bro it's a
one-way
shut up when you driving you don't like
that okay you're supposed to get
everyone to safest destination somebody
give you directions confuses you and
throws you off your Rhythm okay as a
lead my job is to make sure she's safe
my job is to make sure that she's good
and that she gets to each point properly
when she works against me what ends up
happening is that we trip over each
other she doesn't she's not because I'm
paying attention to everything you got
it I'm following I'm leading but I'm
paying attention to surrounding so
nobody steps on her heels so that when
she's going to do return it she got
enough space to do so so that make sure
that all right there's enough space here
we're gonna stay here until these people
move around like I'm in charge of your
safety you're not paying attention the
way I am and so when you're back leading
you're making it dangerous for you and
for me right and so those are little
things like that where it's like if you
just fall back and let it happen first
off the woman is generally the one who
looks the best when we're dancing why
because that's the way these partner
dances work women look the best and two
it's just more fun like I've done both
roles I've learned how to follow I've
learned how to lead learning how to
follows you just let go and it's
actually fun to do yeah because you
gotta you know you're just moving and
then and you you [ __ ] you like you get
these little signals and you know what
to do and it's almost like your ring
turns off which is interesting because
when I'm bleeding it's not the same
thing I'm thinking of like my hand
placement body positioning it's a
completely different brain pattern yeah
but they're fun for different reasons
but it doesn't work unless you just let
it happen to each their role but you
gotta stay in your role and stay in your
lane when you start to back lead
you know when you start a back lead
you're taking over someone's role you're
not anyways all that to say she's right
yeah good video so you guys go check out
her video go check out her Channel you
know sometimes we cover people and they
speak in facts she's so you know shout
outs to her in regards to what she's
doing it's facts she looks a little
young though I don't care uh the reason
why I say that is you wouldn't expect
that kind of wisdom regardless of
Dynamics true maturity from someone that
age but maybe maybe like part of her
feminine energy is her skin care routine
but it doesn't matter the terms mean
something in the row so we understand
okay so like yeah but shout out anything
else yeah good